[Music]
hey everybody this is josh lehrer from
lancaster miami and one of the coolest
parts about my job is the fascinating
people that i get to meet who sometimes
will just walk in off the street with
something really cool and sometimes not
only is the camera cool but the owner of
the camera is cool and i was pleasantly
surprised when mr waterfall himself
kevin o'leary came to see me not just to
say hello but to bring me an absolutely
incredible piece of like a history hey
mr wonderful here now i've got a story
about history i love cameras i've been
trying to be a professional photographer
my whole life haven't quite got there
yet but i started buying cameras way
back way back first was russian cameras
couldn't afford anything else but as i
got a little farther along i got into
leica now leica is for photographers el
supremo the m3 the m6 these are
legendary cameras
but way way back here's where the
history comes in years ago decades ago i
bought a leica m3
in a box
supposedly never used and then i forgot
about it i stuck it in a safe for a
really long time and i was rummaging
through the safe looking at some of my
watches the other day and i saw the
corner of the case
it was my old buddy the leica m3 now
luckily i live in miami so one of the
greatest leica stores on earth is here
josh lehrer's a legend
right a little bit a little bit legend
he's a legend he knows more about leica
than encyclopedia does so i came
screaming in here to get him to look at
this camera and tell me a
is it real b has it ever had a roll of
film put through it and c most important
because i am mr wonderful how much
is it worth
okay
josh baby what's the story on the leica
m3 so this is the first like m camera
this is where leica m begins 1954.
and what's interesting about the m3 is
it is also the most produced m camera
they made right around a quarter million
of them 250 000. so it's not is that
really that's very special if it's never
been used correct because these cameras
were never designed to be collectible or
special they were designed to be tools
to be used
so when you see an m3 of this vintage
not only with all of its accoutrement
box paperwork warranty cards but never
being used never being serviced
that's something special
it's just i mean this looks like the
original box yes this is the original
box so this would have been sold as a
kit
there's actually cameras they sold by
themselves and they sold a couple of
kits
and this kit would have been from about
1959 1960 when the camera was produced
the lens is from 1958 this is what's
known as a double stroke m3 which means
it takes two advances of
right now the m3
has popularity has has waned and has
come back and right now it is absolutely
a renaissance period for the m3 smoking
hot in other words extremely so okay
doubly so with a lens and
the fact that this camera has never been
used
now i can look at this camera now how do
i prove that it's never been used well
there's one giveaway beyond any other
shadow of a doubt which is the strap
lugs these are made from brass yeah that
is an inherently soft metal yeah if i
look at the camera even if a strap had
been on there once
you could tell there would be scratches
there would be nicks these strap lugs
are brand new i have never seen a camera
like this outside of the leica museum in
terms of never been used now you can
combine that with the fact that the
camera actually has what's called the
original l seal yeah which is at the 12
o'clock position on the lens mount
there's a wax seal with the leica letter
l that could only have been put on by
the factory and if anyone ever serviced
this open this up or tinkered with it
that would have been destroyed and
the moment of truth it has the original
lc right there it's not something i can
see here but it does have the original
wax seal here wow so this has never ever
never
i doubt this has ever had a roll of film
through it the condition of this camera
tells me that it not only was never used
but it was cared for because even the
cameras that were put on a shelf tend to
get scratched well it came with this
invoice yes i mean this is from 1960
1960 at 14th of october
the camera was sold your eyes are better
than mine what does that say so the
camera was sold with the lens for 471
dollars but it looks like this gentleman
had a bit of a credit on file so his net
was about 300 and something dollars in
1960.
okay so
what's it worth today if i were to put
this on the market because somebody told
me that these are really hot in japan
they're hot all over the world and you
know i wanted just to find out what i'm
sitting on here sure
a combination of the originality the
provenance of your ownership the tenure
of your ownership yeah i wouldn't ask
less than 10 to 12 000 for this set
probably more
because every day these are going up
this reminds me of antique roadshow this
is the part where i go are you kidding
that's incredible that's amazing now
what about the lens itself i mean is
this valuable on its own the lens has a
lot of value on its own the value is in
the set because this was sold together
the serial number of the lens and camera
appear on the original purchase invoice
as well as all of the original paperwork
so we have the original paper yes but
the most important documentation is the
warranty card this is actually the
import certificate telling you it was an
official leica usa authorized import
from germany and on the back stapled are
the original warranty certificates with
stamped serial numbers for the camera
and the lens that of course so would i
need those in the old days to get it
serviced or just to prove that it was
real well to prove that it was real and
also to get warranty service because
when this was new it would have come
with some warranty oh for you years or
something yeah exactly oh so these are
almost always thrown away it's very rare
to see these still with the camera and
what's really interesting is you have
the sort of quick start guide and the
instruction manual yeah now a lot of
people would take these and buy them on
ebay and throw them in with the camera
but the way that you know these are
original is because they the year
printed which is here 59 yeah actually
matches the year of the camera wow so
these were original with so that makes
it even more valuable oh dramatically so
i mean these cameras just the body only
without any of this provenance and stuff
maybe three or four thousand yeah but
when you start adding all this in plus
the never used condition plus the lens
the paperwork we're five figures deep
ichi
that's fantastic news you know really i
stored this away for a long time
thinking it's going to be valuable one
day but i never thought this much now
let's talk a little bit about this set
of goggles what's the story on this
thing so one of the downsides of the m3
and kind of about rangefinders in
general is you can only focus on this
camera down to one meter which if you
want to do any kind of macro or close-up
work is really not ideal yeah so one way
they got around that is with this lens
called the dual range for two focus
ranges so this has macro this does this
is one of the only lens m lenses ever
produced that actually has a macro
capability and essentially the way it
works is there are two ranges two scales
of focusing on the lens one that goes
from infinity to a meter yeah and one
that goes from a meter to about half a
meter a little less
and what happens is normally if you had
this lens attached to the camera and try
to focus closer than a meter you would
lose your focus calibration so you
couldn't actually focus so hence the
goggle exactly what the goggles do is
they literally go over
the rangefinder optical mechanism and
allow you to focus all the way down to
half a meter so how do you put that on
just to put it on after the lens yeah so
the lens always goes on by itself um so
first you mount the lens yeah the red
dot here
then you put the lens in its macro
position which is you lift up and kind
of most people wouldn't know that
intuitively no i have people come into
the store with these lenses and go i
don't know how to get it into macro mode
and i said ah you have to lift it up and
that frees this little ball bearing here
yeah you slide the goggles on and once
you do you can actually now freely turn
because when you don't have the goggles
on you can't activate and so it's now
accurate there's enough of a correction
being done optically that you can use
macro down to how close uh a little less
than half a meter okay so i don't know
what that is in inches these are always
meters because they're german right
right now what's interesting too is this
lens is still usable on a modern camera
the latest digital m the m11 is actually
the first digital m where this lens with
the goggles has 100 compatibility wow so
that makes this lens so you can put the
goggles on 11 yeah brand new m11 i've
tested this you can use these goggles
and that's the first digital m you could
do that is that they they built that in
sort of for the heritage because how
many people are actually going to have
the goggles and have this lens not a lot
it's more about the way the m11 is
designed and this is a byproduct of that
it wasn't the intent it just so happens
because the m11's light metering system
has changed you can now use the dual
range on the m11 interesting but m11 is
is not really a range finder per se
right it is because you're but you can
also see the image on the back you can
but the fundamental concept behind the
design of every m ever made including
the m11 that came out this year is based
exactly around this
mechanical mechanism so when you use a
rangefinder if i taught you how to use
this m3 and you mastered it yeah and i
gave you an m11 you could get the same
quality of photos but i'm crazy to put a
roll of film through this i would not do
that kevin if i were you because i mean
clearly and if i wanted to sell it i
would work with you because you know
where all the collectors are right
correct there's a certain type of person
that buys a camera to use it and a
certain type of person that buys it to
collect it yeah there's there's some
crossover there but this would be sold
to someone who
is an enthusiast for the m3 looking for
one of the best examples in the world
wow that's really cool to know i own
that that's amazing so i should enjoy
just taking it out showing it to people
and enthusiasts and saying look this is
how this thing works it and it's and the
seal i just learned about the the l seal
that's kind of interesting and there's
not hardly a scratch on the thing it is
in amazing condition i have sold a
couple hundred of these cameras over the
years i've studied the auctions where
they come up for sale and you see
cameras that are nice you see cameras
that have the box but it's very very
very rare to have all of those stars
aligned to have something this nice and
this complete and how many of you seemed
with all of this
two really 12 years the reality is these
are only going up in both collectibility
and design so why would i sell why don't
i just wait i should say with my estate
yeah i don't think you would ever need
to sell it i don't think you ever should
sell it because they will never make
another camera like this because this
exists in its own little bubble of the
like universe no it's just fantastic i
mean what i love about it it looks so
solid i mean they had such a vision back
in the 50s on how to make these cameras
because it looks like you could take it
into war and in fact it did go into war
this camera changed the landscape when
it came out in the 1950s there was
nothing else like it and nobody really
is able to sustainably make something
like this so you need to wind it twice
yet so one of the downsides of the
camera never being serviced is there
could be a little bit of dry lubricant
in the gears that's part of the charm i
would never i would never mess with that
this camera should never in my opinion
have a roll of film through it
well it looks like it looks like it
never did no i don't think so and this
is a late example of the double stroke
1959 so they started doing the double
stroke in the 1960s the way you know
that is the serial numbers over one
million are all double stroke this is a
serial number starting at 974 so it's a
little bit older than that excuse me all
single stroke
newer than a million this is a very late
example of a double stroke model so does
that make it less or more valuable um
it really depends if it was just a body
by itself it would make it a little bit
less valuable yeah but because of the
nature of the set and the completeness
that sort of offsets that and what what
advance did they make so it became a
single stroke well the point of the
double stroke is off debated some people
say it's less wear and tear on the
camera's gearing because it takes two
shorter strokes to advance it other
people say to build up less static
charge inside of the camera body because
it's only a single uh well if you do a
single long stroke they the myth is that
it builds up more charge so that could
in fact affect your film correct yeah
it's never really been
agreed on why the double stroke or what
benefits the double star really had
nowadays people like it just because of
the nostalgic aspect and the additional
mechanical
process involved could you put an 11
beside this just to see how much of the
elements
actually i'll grab a silver one wow it
hasn't changed that much not really no
it's the same concept they've done a
couple of things better since then but
fundamentally it is still what is the 11
cost these days this is just about 9 000
for the bottom so basically i could sell
this and buy that you could you could
availability is tough on these right
yeah for now new like is there's always
a lot of hype but that will
calm down eventually and they'll be able
to the challenge is getting the sensor
chips right combination of factors
they're handmade
all the paint you see is hand done all
the inlay is hand done so they're just
not able to make enough
amazing so people pay nine thousand
dollars for a camera that basically you
can't even see through the lens on it's
a rangefinder well there is live view
now that was one of the improvements
they started about 10 years ago so
you're seeing the actual image well on
the screen or through an optional finder
you can now see through the lens but the
purists guys with m3s right they're
going to use the rangefinder the way it
was meant to be which is through the
optical
viewfinder incredible and these can't
even keep in stock at nine thousand
dollars no we have a quite a lengthy
waiting list as does every other leica
dealer uh around the u.s right okay well
fantastic look i learned a lot here
today is there anything i should do in
terms of storage give us some advice and
we've got all these papers and
everything else what's the game so for
the paperwork um as you know we bagged
it all up individually we didn't want
any of the paperwork um sitting on top
of his other documents right and we
sealed them in like ziploc style and
that's how if it went to auction it
should be everybody should see that it's
insane yes um the camera and lens should
be stored separately in a humidity
controlled environment yeah so we don't
want anything to get fungus or haze
anything like that you don't want to
have it in the box ideally
probably a good place is the same safe
that has my watches in it because
climate control the same kind of idea
because it's a mechanical object right
and every now and then you want to blow
dust off of it make sure it doesn't
collect any dust
wipe it with like a soft microfiber
cloth
you can apply a very light preservative
to the leatherette covering to keep it
from drying out at this point it's
probably pretty dried out
so the main thing it seems to me i'm
doing a single stroke and getting it
look is this a single string yeah let's
see i wasn't able to advance it earlier
look at that
so this what that means is
this is an early single stroke
so it because it's under a million so
what did i say 10 to 12 000 let's make
that 15 000 yeah how about that i just
taught you something john look at that
that's amazing so does that make it more
or less valuable more wow for sure so
it's a single stroke very early yeah
this is a very early single stroke
because
the one million serial numbers you can
look at that and know for sure i wasn't
able to advance it so i didn't know
you got it loose then you have the magic
touch yeah that's amazing exactly well
how about that you know that's that is
three to five thousand dollars of extra
value i think but really the value comes
from the condition and the completeness
and you've owned it for quite a while
yeah i have so that also adds to the
value
but i don't think you should ever sell
it no i'm really falling in love with it
getting all the history and having you
know somebody actually wrote this
invoice with a pen
like think about that that doesn't
happen anymore what's funny is this was
a sporting good store yeah yeah you
bought this camera from give me some
fishing tackle some worms and a leica
seriously it's quite remarkable you
could have walked into a sporting goods
store and picked up this m3 50 dual
range outfit and the fact that you have
the original invoice is remarkable yeah
i remember buying it off a collector and
i was it was under a thousand dollars it
was so long ago i was i was just getting
into photography i think i was still in
my teens i'd worked all summer for that
and you know brought it home and i think
my brother said hey bozo why would you
buy an old camera why don't you get a
new one yeah well well there it turned
out to be a good investment i will say
the market in the last five years has
really gone wild yeah people shameless
watches very true people have started to
appreciate that there isn't anything
like this now and never will be again
yeah i love that that's fantastic well
there you have it we've both learned a
lot today and i love this stuff i mean
just history is so interesting but
history that goes up in value
that's what mr wonderful absolutely
loves
i'm falling in love with this camera all
over again really
just beautiful oh it's so wonderful to
hold it too
it's like a big chunk of metal here yeah
they don't make them like that anymore
yeah and it's so that sounds just
that's gorgeous
well thank you very much i've learned a
lot
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe